okay we want to do a peck we got kisses  on I'll pack you we got kisses  [Music]  I give you a peck  [Music]  oh my God you guys what is what is this  it's uh great for socials all right do I  put my arm around you oh yes  and just a peck right no tongue yeah but  you're looking at me so intimately bro  don't treat me like one of your MILFs  you guys can't see his hands on my leg  it's not even on camera  you know treat me like one of your males  you kiss me like a milk oh my God  [Music]  soft lips and you even gave me one of  them yeah well I didn't even I came here  with that was my gosh  sorry I'm just uh bit smitten here my  goodness I just had a gravy minute there  oh come on too oscillacious man I just  fell off